I think which I find very difficult to
do
yeah
um it's a good it's a good question uh
I've never
frankly I always thought that I
responded to pretty poorly to
uh to losses that I would
especially well
not always when I was little
um I mostly played tournaments with
stronger players so losing was normal
um I just saw it as opportunities to
learn so it was it was fine later of
course I would lose a lot of
important games and they would sometimes
get me quite tilted but uh
I don't know then I just
um
you know
sometimes take a little bit more risks
in the in the next few games and it
would work it would work out a lot but
specifically now and what I can say I
was a lot calmer
frankly I felt that in the two games
that I lost like
you know I hadn't done that much wrong
um
I I was just focusing on trying to
remain
discipline uh discipline like sticking
to the things that I know that usually
work in terms of
what I do for um
for Preparation and my routine and
I I thought like eventually
it's a good that you know it's a good
chance that it will turn around and
like
if I felt that
um I've done
something really really stupid in those
two games I would be more upset I think
but what happened is like in the first
game I played the risky opening uh
trying to play for win against Kiri
um
I fell for a tactic and was was crashed
and in the second game we played a very
very complicated game a second exchange
we both made some mistakes but it was
very very hard to play and and I lost it
was it was was fair enough so I didn't
feel like I've done anything
particularly wrong also like I've been
well rested for for those
um for those games like I was not
forgetting to to eat during the games or
anything so I still felt like I was
doing the right thing so I will
eventually
it will eventually turn around but yeah
in the past it's been I've I've not been
the person to follow when it comes to
to dealing with losses because like I I
become really pissed usually I'm able to
sleep well but I I'm like really pissed
I'm not in a complete
um
um not in uh not in a complete mental
balance for sure
also two losses it's also rare
occurrence I mean you don't have much
experience I think it was 10 10 years
before the last
yeah yeah
like the statistics say that I do very
well after losses but I think
I don't know if I I think that I play a
little bit worse but I also put more
pressure on my opponent so then
I've always thought that he reacted very
well over the board so that when the
game starts next day he's actually seems
to be balanced and such I mean you might
be on tilt and
make some weird choices on watch
football or might or whatever I mean but
that it would always recover in time for
the next game and that's what matters
but yeah usually when I sit down with
the authority I'm exactly that's
something that it seems to be or what
happens before that as long as it as
long as it refers to good thing at the
ball it doesn't matter so much what
happens before
okay